- Hi everybody.
One thing I often hear is
women don't really understand
how to achieve that natural
look with their makeup.
So I'm here with my friend Allison,
and we're going to do a tutorial
on how to achieve that look on your own
with your own makeup.
("Flashing Designer")
The first step is to
start with a pore filler.
Now we're going to apply a
layer of this all over the face
because pores this size at her age
just really aren't natural.
The next step is all over coverage.
Now I chose a BB creme
as opposed to a traditional combination
because it is lighter
and it's going to give a much more
natural smooth finish.
- Oh, it tickles.
- Cover all of that redness
and all those imperfections.
Next we're gonna go in with a concealer.
It's going to give you
that really nice naturally
airbrushed, Photoshop look.
You have some dark circles
under the eye, very common.
Get this little mole here.
- Actually I really like that mole.
I think it gives me character.
- (laughs)
Now we're gonna seal that
all in with a powder.
I chose a mineral powder
because it's made with all
natural ingredients and minerals.
- Where does it end?
- The next step is to contour the face.
This is just going to really enhance
the natural bone structure in your face.
So go ahead and
like a fish.
You look like a fish.
You can see it's enhancing
her natural cheekbone.
Basically we're just going
to reshape your face.
Alright so now you gotta add the blush
right on the apples of the cheek.
This is my favorite part, the eyes.
Since we are going for our natural look
I chose the nudes palette.
You can't really get much
more natural than this.
- There's so many steps.
- Well, you know it is
hard work to look natural.
Nobody's born this way.
Now that we've applied the eye shadow
we're just gonna go in
apply a couple more coats
of concealer, blush, you know.
- You're gonna do it all again?
- Well yeah, you want good coverage.
The final step for the
eyes is the mascara.
We're just gonna make those eyelashes look
bigger, fuller, blacker.
Oh my God.
Alright so we're gonna put on about
three or four coats of this.
- What was that?
That was one coat?
- That was one coat.
The final step is the lip.
It's a really natural nudish color.
So it looks like her skin tone
only a better version.
Oh my God, it's so much better.
Oh my God.
And just like that, that's all it takes
to get that natural look.
- [Allison] I'm probably gonna break out
from all the makeup on my face,
but I guess the good news is
is I can just use more makeup
to cover that up.
("Buy now Pay Later")